[Musique]
la parole est au président patrick
kanner pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain à monsieur le président mais
chez le président mes chers collègues et
monsieur le premier ministre
j'espère que vous allez bien sûrement
mieux que les 1 million quatre français
qui vont tomber dans la trappe à
pauvreté de votre nouveau système dation
au chômage sûrement mieux que les
salariés au smic qui n'auront pas de
coup de pouce en janvier sûrement mieux
que les allocataires de l'apl qui vont
payer cash
votre réforme en 2020 nous y reviendront
sûrement mieux que le revenu de nos
agriculteurs qui attendent en vain les
résultats de la loi et galim sûrement
mieux que nos étudiants qui ont perdu 35
millions d'euros de crédits dans le plfr
2010 9 sûrement mieux que nous aide
soignant urgentistes enseignants
retraités qui ne sont pas dupes
quand il voit la progression est
exorbitante des rémunérations des
patrons du cac 40 et les dividendes de
50 milliards d'euros dont vous avez
alléger la fiscalité ce ruisseau
seulement là celui de l'argent roi
il existe bien c'est vous et vous seul
mais ce premier ministre qui en est
responsable
dans un contexte délétère et anxiogène
terreau de la poussée de l'extrême
droite dans notre pays vous avez franchi
de nouvelles lignes rouges avec vos
annonces de ce midi ces lignes rouges se
nomme âges pivots à 64 ans pris en
compte résiduelle de la pénibilité
c'est une réforme universel certes mais
injuste car avant tout fondée sur un
angle budgétaire et non sur des
principes de solidarité et d'équité
monsieur le premier ministre en écoutant
pas les français pas les corps
intermédiaires
n'êtes vous pas en train de briser notre
contrat social fondements de notre pacte
républicain
pour vous répondre à la parole et à
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le président caennais
rssi je vous écoute
au fond ce que je comprends c'est que
vous m'indiquer que depuis que nous
sommes chose à faire tout va plus mal et
c'est un point de vue et je le respecte
sa conséquence mécanique c'est que au
moment où vous avez quitté les affaires
tout allait tellement mieux et monsieur
monsieur le président caennais ma
lecture à moi et après tout il peut
t'arriver qu'elles diffèrent
ma lecture un mois ne me conduit pas à
penser que au moment où vous auriez
quitté les affaires
tout allait mieux et j'ai le sentiment
mais peut-être est-ce une impression que
c'est ce qu'ont dit les français et donc
comme je suis un démocrate comme vous
j'écoute ce que disent les français et
et j'écoute et j'écoute mais j'écoute
avec beaucoup d'attention
je me permets monsieur le président
kader de vous répondre non pas sur
l'ensemble des points que vous avez
soulevé sa nommé matériellement pas
possible à ce stade mais de dire un mot
sur la retraite vous nous dites monsieur
le président caennais que nous aurions
tort d'indiquer aux français que la mise
en place d'un âge déquilibre du système
à 64 ans en 2027 que de cette mise en
place d'un âge déquilibre à 64 ans en
2027 serait une offense faite à la
situation des françaises et des français
qui doivent pouvoir prendre leur
retraite dans d'autres conditions mais
vous même monsieur le président caennais
avaient j'imagine je ne le sais pas je
suis certain que le compte rendu de
l'époque permettra de le dire vous avez
je crois approuvé une réforme qui avait
pour un pacte s'agissant des régimes du
régime général de faire en sorte que la
durée de cotisation s'allonge très
nettement très nettement de telle façon
d'ailleurs commencera entrera en
application au 1er janvier 2020 de telle
façon d'ailleurs que l'âge moyen de
départ à la retraite aujourd'hui
s'agissant du régime général ces
soixante trois ans et demi et que les
projections a dit qu'avec la réforme que
vous avez
approuvé en 2014 l'âge moyen écoutez moi
bien monsieur le président caennais
l'âge moyen de départ à la retraite
s'agissant du régime général et du
régime général seulement mais c'est 80%
des français sera à 64 ans dans cinq ans
autrement dit monsieur kaner vous êtes
en train de reprocher à ce gouvernement
de dire les choses de façon explicite
est de créer un système dans lequel nous
assumons les choses là où vous là où
vous avez mis en place un système qui
pour le régime général
pas pour les autres mais pour le régime
général conduit à une augmentation
continue des durées de cotisation pour
arriver un âge moyen qui est exactement
celui là eh ben vous voyez monsieur le
président caennais
je trouve que cet échange est
intéressant et qu'il est bon que les
français longtemps
la parole est à notre collègue le
président jean claude requier pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen monsieur le président
vous avez la parole alors qu'une
incertitude mille notre cohésion
nationale
nos concitoyens savent bien eux qui
attendent aujourd'hui de l'équité de la
quartier de la confiance afin de se
projeter dans l'avenir avec plus
d'optimisme
man group et le poids des clients
attentifs à ce que cette réforme ne sont
pas uniquement paramétrique de court
terme comme l'ont appelée de nos voeux
au fil des plfss
cette réforme se doit non seulement
d'intégrer des projections
démographiques et de long terme mais
aussi les transformations des modes de
vie découlant d'un logement d'un terrain
de i
non les seuls conservation budgétaire ne
constitue pas un dogme indépassable nos
compassions aspire à vivre pleinement
une retraite pour le santé après une vie
d'efforts nous avons lancé ce matin en
train de mesures fondées sur les
principes d'un système ce goût-là
universel tenant davantage compte des
pénibilités des disparités de carrière
plus favorables aux femmes et dont
l'entrée en vigueur se ferait
progressivement nous n'aurions et lui
sont en particulier que le parlement
soit associé à la définition de la
valeur du point
il appartient désormais au passé et
sociaux de débattre ce projet dans le
cadre d'un dialogue social apaisé
pour l'heure les français sont très
attentifs et ils ont raison
comment comptez-vous assuré monsieur le
premier ministre qu'aucune catégorie
professionnelle ne soit perdante
vous avez raison c'est une réforme
d'ampleur que nous voulons mettre en
oeuvre peut-être d'ailleurs serait-il
plus juste de parler de refondation du
système des retraites aux fondations car
ce que nous souhaitons c'est substituer
à ces quarante deux régimes existants
un seul régime qui permettrait que
chaque euro cotisé par n'importe quel
française ou français quel que soit son
métier quel que soit son statut quel que
soit son âge puisse produire le même
effet et ouvrir les mêmes droits ce que
nous voulons en font c'est que au lieu
d'organiser la solidarité nationale par
statut ou par profession nous puissions
organiser sur l'ensemble de la nation
ce qui ne me semble pas une mauvaise
idée s'agissant de la solidarité
nationale et ce qui vous le savez
monsieur le président est une forme de
retour aux sources du projet initial de
création d'un système de retraite
on se souvient que enfin se souvient je
ne m'en souviens pas mais je les lui que
les ordonnances de 1945 notamment les
ordonnances par audi avait pour objectif
la création in fine et d'un système
universel ce système universel nous
pensons qu'il est utile et même
indispensable de le créer aujourd'hui et
c'est donc effectivement une refondation
d'ensemble que nous proposons nous avons
indiqué dès le début que notre objectif
ce n'était pas ça et là de faire telle
ou telle petites économies
c'était de dire la vérité aux français
compte tenu des transformations du monde
professionnel compte tenu du caractère h
et des carrières professionnelles compte
tenu des changements d'activité
professionnelle de nos concitoyens du
nombre de polypensionnés de la
complexité actuelle des systèmes de la
perte de droits que chacun subie
lorsqu'il change trop souvent de système
de retraite il nous apparaissait plus
adapté au temps qui viennent de créer ce
système par points par répartition est
véritablement universel et nous avons
dit très tôt très tôt que la france
n'était pas aux faux soumis à des
conditions démographiques radicalement
différente de l'allemagne
de la belgique du royaume uni bref de
toutes les grandes démocraties
occidentales et européennes lesquelles
ont tout tirer les conséquences des
évolutions démographiques en disant que
la seule façon de préserver le pouvoir
d'achat des pensionnés et le pouvoir
d'achat des actifs s'était
progressivement progressivement de
travailler tous un peu plus longtemps il
faut évidemment le faire de façon la
moins brutale possible le faire en
respectant les choix de vie de nos
concitoyens
les prévisions les orientations qu'ils
ont pu retenir dans leur vie
professionnelle dans leur vie familiale
même si josi mais qu' il fallait le dire
clairement c'est ce que nous avons fait
c'est ce que j'ai fait tout à l'heure au
conseil économique social et
environnemental en présentant un projet
de réforme qui j'en ai bien conscience
est complexe et et que je ne peux pas en
2 minutes vous présenter ici j'ai déjà
dépassé largement et le président
larcher nous invite à respecter le temps
il a bien raison mais qui sera débattue
en monsieur le premier vous avez de la
tva
je ne propose pas et donc monsieur le
président au pied ce projet que nous
avons mis sur la table
il a donné lieu à des discussions avec
les organisations syndicales j'ai bien
noté qu'un certain nombre était
totalement opposée au principe d'un
système universel
j'ai bien noté aussi qu'un certain
nombre d'autres n'étaient pas opposés au
principe d'un système universel mais ne
voulait pas dire peut-être assumer que
en effet l' équilibre global du système
pour les années qui viennent reposer sur
le fait que chacun progressivement aller
travailler un peu plus bon eh bien nous
allons discuter ma porte est ouverte
ma main est tendue vous aurez remarqué
que dans le projet que nous avons
proposé après les travaux du haut
commissaire il y a beaucoup d'avancé ce
qui montre que notre objectif c'est de
travailler avec les partenaires sociaux
bien entendu et puis le moment venu avec
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat car ce
débat sera bien entendu discuté à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat et
j'ai même indiqué que je souhaitais que
cette discussion ait lieu rapidement
parce que je pense que ce sujet
passionne inquiète parfois les français
et qu'il faut donc le traité au
parlement jour 1,6
merci monsieur le premier ministre la
parole et à madame la présidente eliane
assassi pour le groupe communiste et
d'oublier un citoyen à l'écologiste
monsieur premier ministre ce midi donc
vous avez franchi la ligne rouge vous
êtes hors jeu et vos annonces vont
continuer à faire coaguler toutes les
colères avec votre projet de casse des
retraites les français vous travailler
plus longtemps jusqu'à 64 ans et
toucheront moins de retraite alors que
les salariés du secteur privé comme du
secteur public et les jeunes sont
massivement mobilisés depuis jeudi
dernier vous maintenez votre projet
funes d'instauration d'un système de
retraite par points soumis aux aléas
économiques et financiers monsieur le
premier ministre effectivement vous
n'avez pas fait d'annoncé magique mais
vous vous êtes lancé dans un excellent
numéro de bonneteau dont personne n'est
dupe
malgré l'illusion de la concertation
sociale
la majorité de la population a bien
compris les dangers de votre projet de
réforme
malgré vos belles promesses qu'il y aura
ni vainqueur ni vaincu
ce qu'ils vont pouvoir se frotter les
mains ce sont les marchés financiers à
l'instar de ses financiers quatre soeurs
reçu par le président de la république
les blacks troc qui vont attirer les
salariés qui le pourront vers les
retraites par capitalisation les lignes
il est triste de votre réforme n'ont pas
bougé d'un iota
il s'agit toujours de mettre fin aux
régimes spéciaux de retraite existants
qui contrairement à vos mensonges sont
tous solidaires du régime général
il s'agit toujours d'un système de
retraite par points dont la valeur
servira de variable d'ajustement à vos
politiques d'austérité avec à la clé une
belle général des pensions et permettez
moi de rappeler ici que ce que la loi
fait un jour une autre loi peut le
défaire demain vous confirmez aussi que
les salariés travailleront plus
longtemps en fixant le fameux âge pivot
je les dis à 64 monsieur le ministre de
points aussi attiré mon attention
volonté de diviser pour mieux régner
en opposant les générations et ensuite
j'ai quand même bien noté que vous ne
touchez pas au capital l'argent-roi que
vous défendez bec et ongles
avec le président de la république alors
ce midi hormis le medef vous n'avez
convaincu personne
à l'instar de beaucoup d'organisations
syndicales monsieur le premier ministre
vous demandons le retrait de votre
projet de réforme vous dit à juste titre
ce qui est vrai dans une démocratie ce
qu'une loi fait une loi peut le défaire
vous avez parfaitement raison mais je
pense madame la présidente que vous
reconnaîtrez qu'une bonne façon compte
tenu de cette évidence démocratique de
procéder c'est de s'engager au moment
des élections sur ce qu'on fera c'est ce
que le président de la république a fait
s'agissant du régime universel de
retraite
c'est ce que la majorité à l'assemblée
nationale a fait en s'engageant au
moment des élections législatives sur le
système universel de leur retraite et
permettez moi de dire madame la
présidente qu'avec le respect que vous
et moi avons évidemment pour la
démocratie le fait qu'un gouvernement
met en oeuvre une promesse
présidentielle ne devrait pas ne devrait
pas me semble-t-il suscité de la
surprise ou même ou même de ce point de
vue là de l'interrogation des premières
choses donc il y a une légitimité
politique deuxième chose on peut sans
doute ne pas être d'accord sur les
mesures mais il ya une chose une chose
qui me paraît évidente c'est que aucune
loi fait ou défait tu ne changeras d'une
certaine façon la réalité de nos
systèmes de retraites et la réalité de
notre système de retraite madame la
sénatrice est la suivante lorsque nous
avons conçu ces systèmes de retraites il
y avait quatre actifs pour un retraité
aujourd'hui il y à 1,7 actifs pour un
retraité
cette mécanique elle est inexorable
inexorable à long terme elle est
inexorable tous les autres pays du monde
l'ont compris l'on assume et en ont tiré
les conséquences et on fait en sorte que
pour préserver le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités
ce que nous voulons faire pour préserver
le pouvoir d'achat des actifs
ce que nous voulons faire le l'élément
déquilibre ne soit pas la valeur du
point mais c'est vrai la capacité
qu'auront nos concitoyens
progressivement à travailler un peu plus
et ça madame la présidente
ça ne changera pas autrement dit
ne pas régler ces sujets c'est s'exposer
un jour dans six mois dans deux ans dans
dix ans à une vérité cruelle la perte de
pouvoir d'achat massive des retraités la
perte de pouvoir d'achat massive des
actifs mais c'est ce qui se passerait
madame la présidente si nous ne faisons
rien c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
faisons un régime universel un régime
universel dans lequel au fond les
françaises et les français ont les mêmes
droits
c'est madame madame la présidente
les mêmes droits les mêmes droits quelle
que soit l'activité professionnelle les
mêmes droits les mêmes devoirs
m'enfin ça devrait vous parlez madame la
présidente les mêmes droits les mêmes
devoirs ses seins dans une démocratie
est dans une république
c'est même la promesse initiale la
promesse initiale du régime des
retraites mais vous le savez
parfaitement
c'était ça elle était portée par votre
camp à l'époque par votre parti et
peut-être même qu'on n'aurait pas réussi
à créer ces régimes de retraite s'il n'y
avait pas eu cette promesse initiale et
vous le savez parfaitement et
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui certains
l'abandonnent pour préserver peut-être
des situations acquises peut-être des
intérêts et bien moi je trouve ça
regrettable
je préfère construire un système
universel clairement conformément aux
engagements qui ont été pris avec un
dialogue avec les organisations
syndicales et patronales et dans la
clarté
je remercie ma question est la suivante
monsieur le premier ministre
premièrement pouvez vous nous assurer de
la détermination du gouvernement
face au blocage présent est annoncée
deuxièmement n'est-il pas temps comme le
proposent certains de nos collègues sur
ses bancs de réfléchir à de nouvelles
dispositions sur le service minimum
garanti
vous répondre la parole et à monsieur le
premier ministre monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président ma durée avec
votre style inimitable et d'ailleurs
illimité vous décrivez une réalité qui
est préoccupante
une réalité qui est préoccupante
la réalité qui fait que trop souvent
chacun se drapant dans ce qu'il
considère un droit et conduit à
méconnaître le droit un autre
le droit de grève et le droit de
manifester sont des libertés
constitutionnellement préserver et
défendu et elles doivent être respectées
nous le savons tous je le dis je le dis
et je l' ai toujours dit je ne crois pas
qu ici peut-être même moins qu'ailleurs
on puisse mégoter si vous me passez
cette expression avec une liberté
publique et constitutionnel mais aussi
bien que le droit de grève et le droit
de manifester
les principes de continuité des services
publics de liberté d'aller et venir de
liberté d'expression de liberté de
travailler et donc de ne pas faire grève
sont des principes qui ont la même
valeur
la même valeur est ce que je dénonce ça
n'est pas que certains fassent la grève
et que d'autres ne la fasse pas que
certains soutiennent les grévistes et
que d'autres les dénonce ce que je
regrette c'est que le choix des uns ou
des autres puissent passer par la
dénonciation des autres
nous vivons dans une démocratie nous
devons assumer nos choix et nos
positions ce qui font grève ont le droit
de le faire mais ils doivent le faire
conformément à la loi
menacer ceux qui ne font pas grève n'est
pas correct et est illégal et nous
savons et je ne dis pas que tous les
grévistes le font bien entendu bien
entendu mais nous savons que dans telle
ou telle entreprise
nous le savons parce que nous le voyons
parce que nous en avons les preuves
des images des films nous savons que
c'est mais ces pressions existent elles
ne sont évidemment pas acceptable de la
même façon tous les mouvements qui
consiste à nier la reconnaissance et
l'existence du droit de grève sont à mon
sens regrettable ce que je veux dire
monsieur le président malhuret
c'est que le gouvernement ne veut pas
opposer les français les uns aux autres
je ne suis pas dans la logique
consistant à dire qu'il y aura des
vainqueurs ou des vaincus
je pense que la solidarité nationale qui
s'incarne dans un régime universel de
retraite est exactement porteuse de la
logique inverse celle dans laquelle tous
les français quel que soit leur statut
c'est vrai quel que soit leur métier
c'est vrai contribuer à la retraite de
tous les français
ce système que nous voulons mettre en
place qui va prendre en compte des
droits nouveaux c'est le système non pas
des français contre les autres français
mais de l'ensemble des français
vis-à-vis des futurs pensionnés et aussi
vis-à-vis de ceux qui paieront les
futurs pensionnés et je veux rester dans
cette logique
vous avez raison les mouvements de grève
se double parfois pas toujours pas
toujours mais parfois de blocage le
blocage mesdames et messieurs n'est pas
autorisé par la loi la loi sur le droit
de grève n'autorise pas à bloquer tel ou
tel dépôt c'est illégal et donc cela
doit être proscrit elle n'autorise pas à
bloquer tel ou tel centre de stockage ou
de production c'est illégal et dont
nous faisons intervenir les forces de
l'ordre pour faire en sorte que ces
blocages ne puisse pas prévaloir
sané ça n'est pas toujours facile car
nous savons très bien
le risque nous savons très bien le
risque que nous courons lorsque nous en
poule lorsque nous engageons la force
publique de cette façon et nous ne
voulons pas céder aux provocations et
nous ne voulons pas qu'un incident
puisse ensuite développé le désert mais
je le dis clairement monsieur le
président malgré la grève c'est
constitutionnel
on ya droit le blocage c'est
inconstitutionnel
on n'a pas le droit et la continuité du
service public c'est pas quand tout va
bien la continuité du service public
c'est justement le principe qui impose
aux fonctionnaires ou aux agents publics
de poursuivre leurs activités quand
c'est l'intérêt du service public des
françaises et des français et donc d'une
certaine façon
l'intérêt de la nation sur ce terrain
nous sommes évidemment déterminée a
rappelé les principes et le cas échéant
à en compléter à en compléter les
dispositions nécessaires mais je le dis
je le dis aussi monsieur le président
malhuret nous connaissons tous le rythme
auquel les lois qui intervient dans la
matière doivent être discutés nous le
savons tous les grandes propositions qui
interviennent la veille d'un mouvement
de grève sont souvent des façons
d'attirer l'attention du public sur un
sujet est peut-être un peu moins une
façon de régler durablement une question
juridique délicate
le ch le premier league vous aviez
prévenu le député de la majorité hier en
disant qu'aujourd'hui il n'y aurait pas
d'annoncé magique dont acte le ministre
du budget et des comptes publics
répètent souvent ici lors des débats
budgétaires qu'il n'ya pas non plus de
chiffre magique et il a bien raison
cependant après vous avoir écouté
attentivement ce midi il nous manque
quelques petits éléments pour comprendre
où nous allons exactement d'une part
vous allez devoir rééquilibrer le
système de retraite actuel dont le corps
nous dit qu'il sera déficitaire entre 10
et 17 milliards d'ici 2025 et d'autre
part vous allez mettre en place
progressivement le nouveau système qui
accorde des garanties individuelles
notamment aux enseignants mais qui va
également accordé des droits nouveaux et
je pense aux mille euros de pension
minimum pour tous alors si l'on a bien
compris que le retour à l'équilibré du
système actuel sera la sphère des
partenaires sociaux avec l'âge pivot à
64 ans d'ici 2027 et non 2025
vous n'avez rien dit monsieur le premier
ministre du coup des mesures de
transition et des mesures nouvelles ni
de la manière dont vous allez les
finances et voilà ma question on réponde
la parole et à monsieur le premier
ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur m'interroger sur le
rythme auquel nous nous proposons de
basculer dans le régime futur et sur les
questions importantes d'équilibrage du
système actuel et du système futur c'est
beaucoup de questions et je reconnais
qu'elle ne sont pas simples
je voudrais essayer de répondre le plus
simplement possible dans le système
futur une fois que tout aura été mis en
place
la responsabilité reviendra c'est vrai
aux partenaires sociaux et au parlement
le système futur comme le système actuel
d'ailleurs il sera financé à 75% par des
cotisations et à 25% par l'impôt dès
lors qu'il est financé à 75% par des
cotisations et 25% par l'impôt il n'est
pas illégitime
ils ne semblent même nécessaire que les
partenaires sociaux soient représentés
actifs et centraux dans les décisions
qui sont prises et que le parlement soit
associé centrale aussi dans la
définition du pilotage de ces opérations
il reviendra à la gouvernance future de
fixer des règles d'équilibré par période
de cinq ans car comme le
haut-commissaire l'indiqué il nous
semble que assurer la modification des
éléments par période de cinq ans c'est
ne pas placer le système dans un
décalage ou dans un déséquilibre trop
durable et ça ne fait pas peser la
nécessité de l'adaptation sur une seule
année
il y à des pays dans lesquels la
nécessité de l'équilibré se fait année
par année je pense notamment à la suède
où il ya aussi un régime de
capitalisation à côté du régime de
répartition et bacchantes
quand il ya une retour d'un retournement
du cycle économique où une crise
financière l'ajustement il doit se faire
sur une année et ça a conduit la suède
en 2008 ou 2009 à faire baisser le
niveau de ces pensions nous ne voulons
pas cela et donc nous voulons un
équilibrage sur cinq ans pour faire en
sorte que les changements de cycles
économiques puissent être absorbée et
lycées ça ça reviendra à la gouvernance
future
au fond on pourra jouer sur des
paramètres qui sont en vérité les mêmes
qu'aujourd'hui la durée du travail le
taux de cotisation le niveau des
pensions
mais nous aurons indiqué c'est la règle
d'or que le point ne baissera pas qu'il
devra évoluer dans le futur à la même
vitesse que l'évolution des salaires ce
qui est une grande garantie
vous le savez parfaitement pour les
retraités de demain pour les retraités
demain voilà ça c'est le système futur
le déséquilibre actuel nous le
constatons il est lié au système tel
qu'il fonctionne depuis longtemps il y a
trois ans le corps qui est un institut
est une institution parfaitement
respectable est d'ailleurs parfaitement
respecté disait que à l'horizon 2025
on était à l'équilibré les hypothèses
ont changé je ne prononce pas sur la
façon dont le travail est fait je sais
qu'il est bien fait néanmoins ce que
nous constatons c'est que quelques mois
après l'élection présidentielle le corps
a dit finalement l' équilibre ne sera
pas préservée et que lorsque j'ai
interrogé le corps pour justement mettre
tout sur la table pour dire la vérité
pour ne pas spéculer mais au contraire
montrer les projections les plus
récentes le corps nous a dit qu'il y
avait en fonction des hypothèses un
déséquilibre de l'ordre de 7 à 17
milliards qui était attendu et bien nous
devons le régler par en une fois pas en
une seule mesure mais nous devons dire
aux français comment progressivement
nous allons régler cette question d'un
déséquilibre qui est de l'ordre de 7 à
17 milliards par an 7 à 10 7 milliards
par an en 2025 mais qui s'accroît très
ensuite bon nous avons dit j'ai dit ce
matin que pour permettre la mise en
place du système futur nous proposions
que la trajectoire d' équilibre soit
commencée au 1er janvier 2022 et qu'elle
permette d'arriver à l'équilibré du
système ancien en 2027
c'est la proposition que j'ai faite en
écoutant ceux qui disaient vous ne
pouvez pas faire commencer des mesures
d' équilibre au moment nous discutons du
système universel ce que je peux
parfaitement entendre et ce qui est
probablement une
la meilleure position à adopter il
reviendra je les dis ce matin à la
nouvelle gouvernance de définir cette
trajectoire est de définir les
mécanismes qui permettent de la garantir
mais parce que je ne renoncerai jamais à
mes responsabilités
jamais j'ai dit que si cette trajectoire
n'était pas définie par un accord entre
les partenaires sociaux
alors le gouvernement assumerait ses
responsabilités et or a placé dans la
loi cadre qui sera examiné par le
parlement au premier semestre de l'année
2020 à l'assemblée nationale je l'espère
dans le premier trimestre au sénat dans
le second trimestre que la loi
prévoirait des mesures qui à défaut
s'appliquerait si la nouvelle
gouvernance n'arrivait pas à définir les
conditions du retour à l'équilibré c'est
ça que j'ai dit ce matin et ça se
passera par une augmentation par une
incitation pas par une obligation par
une incitation à travailler
progressivement
c'est vrai un peu plus longtemps
autrement dit monsieur le sénateur les
choses sont claires elles sont dites
nous ne nous payons pas de mots et nous
assumons nos responsabilités
c'est à ce prix que nous pourrons
construire un système universel
équitable et responsable
j'ai bien compris qu effectivement les
partenaires sociaux devraient trouver le
chemin mais il ya par exemple pour les
enseignants l'augmentation des
traitements que vous allez devoir mettre
en oeuvre pour leur permettre
effectivement de bénéficier à terme d'un
même niveau de retraites combien a coûté
cette mesure elle va bien peser sur le
budget de l'état et elle va montrer en 1
valmont terre le progressivement
président de la république avait dit 10
milliards si mes souvenirs sont bons il
ya quelques mois les 1000 euros minimum
pour tous
combien ça va coûter qui va l'assumer le
système ancien ou pas voilà les
questions je vous pose est alors le
gouvernement a déjà abandonné l'objectif
du retour à l'équilibré des comptes
publics en 2022 la question c'est où
allons nous dans les cinq ans qui
suivent
voilà la question qui est posée et
j'espère que d'ici le débat ici au mois
de février le parlement sera
parfaitement éclairé parce que voter une
loi cas alors c'est bien mais sans en
comprendre les conséquences ça nous
paraît pas acceptable
merci
[Musique]